first off welcome to Klaudia huddle
my name is beneath and you know I'm on
cloudy I engineering team focused on AI
developer adoption and so it's all again
about you I would like to invite you to
check out two of her links the bitly AI
huddle in which the TLDR the over there
is you know AI huddle is the open
collaborative developer first forum
which is driven by Google AI expertise
and this is a forum where you get
connected with Googlers and will help
you solve your AI problems right and the
second thing is which we launched or
announced last week was cloud a I office
hours it's still in the pilot and it's a
program where you can connect over VC
virtual conference with Googlers and
talk through some of your problems
you're facing right and it's it's a
great way to get unblocked in a really
quick fashion and then also a quick
shout-out to our entire cloud AI
community we have 950 members as of
yesterday and again it's it's a
shout-out to you all so thank you so
much for the enthusiasm and just sort of
continue the momentum and help us help
you unblock in your a I journey with
that I'll hand it over to Shantanu Shan
Thoreau take it over yeah hi I'm Anthony
I'm gonna do a quick intro although
Bryan is amazing I don't know if I can
cover all of this quickly but Bryan
Kobayashi kava is a senior interaction
designer on the cloud ai team at Google
and the workflows that you're going to
see today were designed by Bryan so
basically you know from the inception
like from scratch you know going from
zero to what you're going to see today
it's it's been an amazing journey and we
launched Auto ml vision recently and so
you will get to see
to certain extent how we actually
arrived at some of the design decisions
Brian
previously worked in the material design
team at Google and before that he's
worked at various UX organizations
including multi-year stints as their
need visual designer for Yahoo Mail and
yeah messenger
what are you Brian alright well thanks
very much ok alright so yeah I think the
agenda for tonight's gonna be fairly
straightforward will sort of start off
with just an introduction to Auto ml
vision overall then we'll sort of jump
into a demo hopefully a live demo and
then after that's kind of the part
that's that sort of strikes me as being
have the most salient part from my
perspective is the deeper dive into the
user experience or the UX and so as a
result this talk will probably be a
little bit different than probably the
previous AI meetups in that it's sort of
focusing very much on how you know
products our product experiences are
designed at Google and especially
serving this nascent emerging AI space
and how we're sort of trying to sort of
tackle the myriad you UX challenges that
are sort of present throughout these
experiences so first off let's go with a
start with an introduction to auto and
low vision and to kind of start with
that we have sort of the mission for the
computer vision group as a whole and
that's sort of to help developers build
next generation computer vision powered
autonomy solutions and so this blue bar
over here sort of represents kind of the
the area of work that that we're sort of
focused on that being are pre-trained
machine learning api's and auto ml auto
ml being there are three products that
launched at Google next 2018
just a few months ago that the auto
Bella vision auto ml natural language
and auto ml translation and the
foundation for those ml api's auto are
sort of the technologies and research
and
the various the decades of research of
work that have happened on the the
Google machine perception team sort of
the investments into tensorflow and and
composted CPUs sort of drive these sort
of development of these of these
products which can then in turn drive a
variety of different use cases and those
use cases can span a large variety or a
large sort of gamut sort of ranging from
from energy like say for like in the
vision case like being able to detect
detect spots of corrosion on a wind
turbine for example all the way to
something like retail where maybe you
have a product catalog and you want to
recognize objects in photos that match
that that catalog so as it turns out the
pre-trained machine learning api the
vision API is sort of that can actually
address a lot of those use cases so it's
sort of the it's a pre trained model it
has a variety of different features and
you can learn more about it at cloud
agribe.com slash vision but the sort of
the variety of features that it has are
sort of presented here these bottom four
on the on the bottom right the
handwriting OCR product search object
localizer and web detection were were
announced at next 2018 back in july but
there's sort of like a variety of
different use cases that or that these
features sort of handle ranging from you
know optical character recognition being
you know sort of being able to like scan
and and and transfer large amounts of
paper documents at scale to to labeling
to logo detection image properties like
yes or common colors or dominant colors
so the the pre-trained vision API would
sort of handle a lot of these these
particular cases and if you go to the
the ml api section on the cloud website
you'll see that there's a video
intelligence api there's a natural
language api translation api translation
API has been around for a while actually
but the question sort of emerges is what
happens if you're if the data that
you're looking for
the objective that you're you're sort of
going for it sort of belongs to a
different domain and you need to support
these very specific concepts that may
not necessarily be covered by the vision
API and so probably the answer that a
data scientist might might come up with
is that they would create their own
computer vision model and so over here
we sort of have sort of laid out you
know sort of very roughly had the
different stages of constructing that
that model but along that way there's
sort of a variety of questions that that
data scientists would be asking and
these are sort of questions that have
have come up sort of in in the UX
research and are and other sort of
initiatives that we've been we've been
doing in the past such as when you're
when you're sort of doing your data
pre-processing pre-processing
one of the questions you might ask is
like well what pre-processing techniques
should I use when I move over to the
next couple stages the you know the
model of design and being able to tune
those parameters the questions that
those users would ask would be all what
what techniques should I be using if I'm
doing deep learning what which
architecture should I be selecting and
what sort of hyper parameters should I
be tuning and then once you move over to
the evaluate step then it starts to get
into sort of this whole this whole this
whole goal around being able to sort of
analyze that data like understanding
what metrics are sort of most important
or most relevant to my objective how do
I know that my model is actually
performing well what are some ways for
me to actually improve my dataset so
that if I were to retrain it would
actually produce better results and then
and then for deployment then there's a
question around what you know
infrastructure should I be using to be
able to serve this model at scale and
we're like how do I meet my overall
latency goals and and and then there's
like this process of updating and then
that sort of cycles back to the previous
step and so you might end up asking
these questions multiple times as you're
starting to go through and and kind of
improve your data set and and as as your
survey answering these questions along
the way that could start to get pretty
expensive as you're starting to like you
know choose all these different pathways
and see what what combination sort of
works best and produces the best outcome
so and then and then anytime that you
were to say
change your objective or shift it around
then you kind of have to start over from
the beginning
in many cases so what we started to look
at with Auto ml is being able to take
all those the you know those those
complex steps of building an ml model
and being able to automate it somehow
and the way that we'll show it is we'll
sort of see how it sort of manifests in
in a user interface but what's the sort
of goal of all ml at that point is that
it sort of allows you to focus on the
you know actually collecting the right
data and being able to define the right
business objectives and still have a
model that's of high enough quality that
you could deploy to production and so
the workflow that you sort of then sort
of manifests kind of gets distilled down
to well you can certainly put you put
together your data set with some
training images and labels you pass it
into Auto ml which will sort of do the
whole process of training your model to
pulling your model and serving your
model on Google Cloud and then what you
end up with is a simple rest interface
for making those types of predictions so
what types of capabilities does auto ml
currently have or Automall vision
currently have well we have single label
classification so this is sort of like
the case where you might have an image
that should be only one of several
classes so the example that we bring up
here is one where you're sort of trying
to distinguish different cloud types
from each other based on like the
overall sort of you know physical
properties visual properties of these
clouds and this could be you know one of
those inputs to help build a you know a
pretty good indication of what the
weather is gonna be like another case
would be something like a the other sort
of side of it would be multi-label
classification where an image can have
several classes so one example might be
maybe you want to create like this giant
latte our database and you have all
these different sort of indicators of
what you know what types of properties
this this lot area should have and you
know maybe maybe at some point you want
to like when people upload new images of
their latte art they can sort of had it
automatically categorized and you know
easily browsable and all that but this
would be a case where like it would not
you you wouldn't not necessarily want
feather to win out over latte or etching
to win out over
but rather it's like they would also
share this those common properties so so
what what kind of happens sort of under
the hood is that is that Auto can't
actually use AI to build AI so what
we're sort of neat what we sort of mean
by that is that we actually introduce
once you submit your dataset 200 ml AI
agent will sort of come in and sort of
be able to build this sort of this model
that uses deep luring techniques that
has sort of the optimal architecture as
the type of parameters to solve your
particular business need and we're that
sort of manifests like back in April
there was this article that came out
that that showed this Japanese
researcher over and that was able to
take photos of Raman and there's this a
shop called ramen Jiro they have 40 some
locations and what what this researcher
was able to do was like take believe a
thousand photos from each of those shops
and then be able to pass that into auto
ml train it for about 24 hours and when
when all was said and done it was able
to predict were which specific shop that
Raman came from with something like a 95
percent accuracy that being like 94
point something percent recall and a
four point something percent precision
so that was like an interesting case
because like I I myself in a a giant
Raman fan so I was kind of a there's
very rare that article is about AI make
you salivate
it was happen to be one of one of one of
a couple but anyway so so were you I
starts to get involved is this whole
process of creating user stories and
scenarios and so we'll start with kind
of a simple one so we'll start with us
this user will call her Jane she's a
developer at a Wildlife Conservancy
maybe she's familiar with cloud vision
API but she's probably familiar with
like implementing api's in general she
have this have a lot of images on hand
but she has very direct little direct ml
experience she's more of an ml
enthusiast and so unfortunately this
this uh pose a little washed out but
it's a little slow out of a flightless
bird right there so what she wants to do
is create a vertical
Farra so she can improve the experience
that for ornithology app so maybe what
ends up happening is she ends up using
the vision API sort of pre-training
vision API to handle a lot of her
labeling techniques or labeling tasks
but in the case of like being able to
distinguish he moves from cassowaries
from Ria's to ostriches she wants to
create an even more custom model to sort
of address that and so what will be some
ways that she might she might do this
well there's a couple of different
approaches one is that you could sort of
use this sort of Wizard of Oz approach
where when users submit images will sort
of she'll sort of surreptitiously take
these images and send them to a human
labeling pool somewhere that will sort
of go in and and label these images for
her and send it back and then this gets
sort of indexed by the database but you
could sort of see where the this starts
to get not all that scalable in the long
run where you know the the cost will
sort of increase as the number of users
increases the number of if if she
decides to expand her reach beyond just
these four classes then that starts to
complicate how she interacts with a
labeling service and you know if she
wants it she wants results in the matter
of seconds by then you know minutes or
days then this is probably not the right
solution for her another possibility is
that she could use the vision API but as
mentioned earlier these categories may
not necessarily be all that specific
enough to meet her her use case the
third option which we kind of brought up
a few slides back is that she could
write them all herself but as mentioned
by her personal description she doesn't
have the AML expertise to go to build
that model so what we sort of offer as
kind of the the ultimate solution is to
use auto ml vision where Google can
basically train a model off of her own
images and labels so this is where we
get into a demo and hopefully this will
work so this is a so kind of as a setup
this is a I had created a folder called
Birds on the left and within there I
created four folders with the different
labels that I want and then within each
of those folders I sort of just threw in
all the images that are that I want
labeled ostrich or EMU or Pia
if I can go here I'll create a okay I'll
go here and this is the on television
sort of interface this is me creating a
new data set so I can go here and say
okay I'll call this birds and from here
I can import my images and there's three
different options so one option is the
one that sort of is suited for my
purpose which is to basically just
upload these images from my computer
where I just select these files and I'll
say okay I'll take this bird stencil
just sort of pop it like so the other
main option that we have is that you can
select a CSV file on Google Cloud
storage and this would be particularly
useful if you have like very like a
Norden new large amount of images in
which case you might want to use Google
Cloud storage as tools in order to get
you know massive numbers of images onto
into your data set the other possibility
is that maybe you want to control the
the training validation testing split in
which case you can sort of specify what
what bucket it should go into within the
CSV file itself and so there's like a
little little surf code over here that
kind of describes what how that search
syntax kind of works where you have the
path to your your the location of your
of your of your image on Google Cloud
storage and then you follow with a comma
and then put the label or labels after
it and then if you wanted to sort of
specify what whether it's in training
validation or testing then you would
prepend that line with training
validation or test and so this is sort
of more for like kind of users that are
maybe a little bit more events that
would sort of know how data splitting
works and have best practices around it
so we kind of don't necessarily surface
it at this point given that we handle
the split sort of automatically if they
just sort of leave it empty for now and
then the third option is that they can
import their images later so they
essentially start with it with an empty
data set and then they can through the
interface itself they can you could they
can throw in their images and sort of
label them either sort of label them
manually within the UI or use or use the
humanly labeling service that's also
built into the
and then this last option over here is
just basically specifying what the
classification type it is so whether
it's it's sort of single label
classification by default but so you can
optionally choose to make this
multi-label classification so at this
point I would hit create data set and
then it would sort of churn for some
amount of time it sort depends on the
size of your data sets but I think for
this one it took probably about 20 or 30
minutes or so
and then we're not going to wait 20 or
30 minutes here because I don't really
have a whole lot to say between that
time
so what I'll end up doing is I'll just
start skip over to the actual created
data set here so it's worse so if I my
internet connection has been kind of
wonky that all day so we'll see so so
here this is after I upload my zip file
through that create form and 20 or 30
minutes later it serve pops in this sort
of browser over here and so I could sort
of see all the images that I that were
imported and the labels that are
associated with them over here and for
the more what I can do is I can sort of
narrow it down to a specific label here
by clicking on this item over here
so I started near a data just the
cassowary use for you over here and I
see my my ostriches and what I can also
do is I can go in to individual images
over here and say you know this this
particular image right here this you
know say hypothetically that this wasn't
an emu is actually an ostrich I can go
in here and say this is an ostrich hit
okay and then it will sort of update
that data set so you can serve going
kind of like one by one and update these
update these images or you can select it
over here and you can do like sort of a
click you can do selector do multi
select over here to do multiple multiple
images and hit the label button and sort
of do a mass mastery labeling of these
images to say for example EMU so it's
all sort of like kind of built in here
and like it's sort of also built to
handle sort of a large list of labels as
well so you have access to like you know
filtering over here so I can like to
filter it down to cassowaries this way
or I can search select on here there's
like a filter over here so it's sort of
like kind of geared towards like being
on the order of like you know a hundred
a couple hundred labels they can
potentially have having this case once I
move over to the train tab this would be
sort of the next step and at this point
IV ordinarily I'd be served prompted
with the sort of a prominent call to
action to allow me to train a new model
so I I click on this guy and I could I
can say okay this is my model and I'll
give it a one compute our training
budget which is free for the first ten
models for each month I also have the
option of specifying a larger number of
compute hours which we'll get to later
and so once once you source submit your
train request
it'll sort of churn for some another
amount of time and I think in this case
it took about fifteen to twenty minutes
or so and produced a model that looks
something like this
I also actually trained two miles this
morning actually this one performs
slightly better than this one so the
results that I get is that I get serve
an average precision of zero point nine
four seven and if I were sort of a one
that was not sort of accustomed to these
particular values I might serve look at
this tooltip and say okay what is what
is this zero point nine whatever mean
and so then if over here it says that
one point zero is the maximum score so
that sort of means that it's looking
pretty good right now my precision and
recall are are good but not great
so maybe what I'll do is I'll take a
look at the full evaluation and see
what's going on and so this was sort of
clicking that see full evaluation takes
me to the third tab in this list which
is the evaluate tab and from here I can
sort of take a look at the all labels
panel and get sort of like sort of a
deeper dive into these precision recall
graphs so I can sort of move my score
threshold around and sort of see how
these how that sort of affects these the
precision recall graph as well as the
precision at one and recall at one graph
so for a more a more
advanced ml user they could sort of see
here like what threshold would sort of
make the best soar trade-off between
precision and recall or if they want to
sort of like anchor and more towards
recall they can move it over here which
would sort of produce more false
negatives as false positives and then if
I were to move it over here then it
would sort of anchor it more towards
precision and then down below here
there's a confusion matrix so the Cir
gives you have a four by four of the
true labels versus the predicted labels
and when I sort of look at this over
here I can see that for cassowary and
emu it actually performed pretty well
for ostrich it performed okay you know
85 percents is good but not particularly
great but it really suffered on on the
Rhea class and so it looks like it
confused RIA with ostrich quite a bit
and having looked at at birds for the
last couple days it it seems that that
Ria's indeed although there are much
smaller bird and they come from a
different continent I believe they're
from South America as opposed to Africa
they look astonishingly like ostriches
and I was know something I was not
entirely aware of so so if I go over
here I could sort of see kind of like a
specific precision recall curve for this
particular label and I can see the list
of true positives that came back for
this particular for this particular
label so these are all different Ria's
and I can see some of the false
negatives so this would be like photos
that were properly identified as Ria's
but we're not about that point five zero
score threshold that I had specified up
here and then down here are some false
positives I got so these are ones where
it was labeled RIA but or it it should
have been that these are these are
ostrich photos but we ended up
predicting RIA for whatever reason and
like in this case like this is clearly
an ostrich but for whatever reason it's
the Aria label sort of edged it out for
for whatever reason and and that
whatever reason is is we're sort of
building that kind of that that's sort
of intuition around how this model is
sort of working starts to allow these
are two kind of
formulate some some interesting
follow-up actions on like you know what
should they do next to sort of improve
their model so what an option that they
could potentially do is you know sort of
is this one that we sort of say up here
is that basically if you were to add
more images to your data sets this would
probably allow you to improve your model
and if I look at my label stats I
actually only upload just a couple
hundred images for each of these labels
and as it turns out you know for
cassowary and emu I mean maybe maybe
this might suffice because like it seems
to perform pretty well but for ostrich I
had 400 images and for reai only had 200
images maybe I should add more RIA
images in order to see if I can get my
my metrics up another possibility that I
might want to do is just take a look at
these images and see maybe I might have
mislabeled from these images and so like
in this case like this one was the
ground truth as an ostrich but I think
this is actually a real and I think
maybe I just may I just went in this
label these images so so another thing
that could potentially do is backtrack
to the Images tab over here and and go
to my RIA section and and basically kind
of scan through and see if there if
there are if all these areas and then
likewise go to my ostrich section and
see if any of these are mistakenly
identified as Ria's when they should
really be ostriches so this could be
something that maybe I might I might do
or it's something that could sort of
offload to a co-worker of mine maybe
it's something that I can sort of you
know export export this data set to a
CSV file and sort of looking at this
offline there's a couple of different
ways to go about that and then the last
option that's you could potentially do
is is it's basically through a more
compute hours at this model so we only
train it with one computer which
actually translates to about four
fifteen to thirty minutes or so but if I
were to safe train a new model and give
it a much more substantial training
budget it's quite possible that that
throwing more computer computers will
give me a better model with the same
data but this is something that you can
sort of you know you can max out on but
you can also sort of customize you can
say maybe I just want to try out two at
first and then see how things perform
and then I can go back and sort of
resume train
with an additional set of compute hours
so there's a couple of different options
kind of at my disposal as far as like
going in and sort of intervening and see
if seeing if I can squeeze better
performance out of this model and then
the last step that that the user can do
is go to this predict section and they
can serve this is sort of like the
moment of truth where they can sort of
click this button and upload some
holdout images so I have added this
image over here this appears to be an
emu so we'll see if this thing will
actually work and yeah it looks like it
predicted an emu with 0.99 six percent
score ostrich was slightly represented
Ria's slightly represented but it's kind
of almost so infinitesimal that it might
not even matter all that much and if I
had said the score threshold of 0.5 then
this would be sort of created as an emu
perilous and then down below we have the
ability of sort of code samples that
will allow you to implement your custom
model so we provide some snippets for
the REST API and you can toggle over
here to see sort of like a little a
little mini Python script so that you
can serve like if you're sort of a
person that happens to have a lot of
training images on hand but maybe not
necessarily a lot of programming
experience you can sort of take this guy
and kind of copy it and paste it and
send it to your web developer and say
hey can you uh can you help out here and
see if we can get this thing to work but
in the meantime the model itself has
been deployed to and is sort of readily
available for predictions so yeah so
that's basically kind of the long and
short of of the workflow and Sony just
go back to the presentation and so how
so like we can from here we can sort of
conjure up some ideas on like how all
this sort of fits together like you know
different pieces so like unfortunately
there's sort of like a battery that sort
of platform system and so one workflow
that you could sort of imagine is that
maybe a user uploads new images you know
from their computer it gets sent into
Google cloud platform it
stored on cloud storage which would then
trigger I do image notification via the
pub/sub Google cloud product which then
gets sent to App Engine which is what
this the search in the search index is
based on and what's what can happen
there is that well App Engine could
serve call the auto ml vision API and
say ok I got these three new images what
do these images look like and the
autoblow vision API can return back
predictions on well this is an ostrich
this is an emu this is a reinstall that
in a search index on App Engine so
that's step 5 the user can can search
for say ostrich Maria and be able to get
those results sort of automatically
tagged on their behalf now let's take a
let's take a step back and take a deeper
dive into the user experience so user
experience or UX is kind of in the most
sort of most general terms at least at
Google loosely split into these three
different branches
so there's UX research qyx design and UX
prototyping and you sort of see that one
feeds into the other and there's
actually some hidden arrows that were
sort of cycles back in on itself but so
it's sort of like a primer on what these
three different disciplines are so UX
research is all about sort of like you
know better understand the problem space
and that could be sort of through sort
of interviews with stakeholders with
customers doing academic research being
able to sort of gather insights from
sort of a whole spectrum of sources
being able to sort of you know provide
meaningful analysis and also sort of
interpret to the results so that I can
it can be translated into sort of
actionable steps not just for UX design
and prototyping but also for the product
management team for engineering etc but
as far as the scope of this discussion
the the primary artifacts from UX
research feed into the UX design which
is sort of the area that I that I'm most
kind of rooted in and that started all
around like kind of constructing the the
flows the sort of the overall user
journey the the way that the the way
that the
products are constructed from like a
visual and information hierarchy
standpoint it can also encompass visual
design and motion design so like things
like transitions or what components are
being used and how they sort of look
like the aesthetics are all sort of part
of that kind of kind of realm and then
that feeds into UX prototyping also kind
of known as UX engineering at Google and
that sort of is the ability to sort of
take all these design and research
artifacts and sort of encapsulating it
into something that we can sort of
something that's tangible that we can
serve show to stakeholders to other team
members and be it as a spec or as a
demonstration or most importantly in our
case to our to UX research participants
so this sort of gives us like an early
sort of look at like how how the design
is going without necessarily getting too
deep into the implementation side of
things and the way that prototyping
started manifests you know within the UX
field is that sort of takes a variety of
different levels of fidelity like a
concern range from very low fidelity
like you know just a series of pieces of
paper that had like it was just a bunch
of diagrams I had that you serve just
like show kind of in sequence that kind
of mix it around it could be something
like a Google slides deck or a
PowerPoint deck where it's like a series
of mock-ups they serve take take a
participant through or a stakeholder
through but then it can again to the
very high fidelity where it's like it's
actually you know a semi interactive or
fully interactive products that a
participant can you know sort of
directly interact with and sort of see
you know how does this sort of like
meets their their expectations and so
one one way that the sort of benefits is
here on all ml where this is sort of
like the live demo - oh right here this
other tab right here is is the ux
prototype that we've been building over
the last however long and this is
basically something that is using not
real data but it's it's using as many
sort of ux patterns and components put
together to see
how that sort of maps to users
expectations and allows us to sort of
get a kind of a head start on on how the
how our our design thinking is going
without leaping directly into you know
lugging a bunch of Engineers to like
make a bunch of back-end and front-end
modifications that may end up you know
not testing well and so so like in this
case like you can sort of see like that
there's like this is all fairly
functional like you can serve can't go
any like you know select a bunch of
images you can assign some labels and
you know do all sorts of like activities
that you would normally do with a live
product but this is sort of all done
kind of all through smoke and mirrors
essentially as basically kind of use
more or less like a inherently
disposable tool that we can we can use
to do some rapid iterations on so like
one example which unfortunately well not
particularly well on the screen was with
a confusion matrix where you know we
originally had started off with a matrix
that looked kind like this where the
positive values or the matches were
green the negative ones were red but a
concern came up that you know people
with red-green color blindness may not
necessarily see that sort of diagonal
strip of green in the center there
actually calyx all like shades of shades
of yellow or brown so what we ended up
doing was like try use this prototype as
a means of being able to try out a
couple of different different color
palettes so like being able to see okay
let's see it what looks like with a blue
grey themed you'll ultimately sell it on
the blue orange theme over here because
it sort of gives like a fair amount of
prominence between the two but the
ability that we can serve like I've just
sort of toggle between these different
variants without necessarily impacting
the rest of the flow or like having to
crank out a bunch of additional mock-ups
was one of the key pieces that we got
out of this one another kind of quick
example is like looking at is looking at
what these images over here you can sort
of see the predictions on the right and
but one thing that we're thinking about
well what if we merge does just sort of
tweak the layout so that we want this
column to appear on the left hand side
so as opposed to like making a request
through to our friend you're like you
know try this out see how it feels we
could just sort of like try it out on
the side see see where the pros and cons
of this particular layout you know
the things become more readable that's
readable how does this sort of ally with
you know how they've interacted with
previous products in the in Google cloud
etc so if I jump back to the
presentation here so as we started to
like kind of do a series of these
iterations like we had multiple rounds
of testing on the research side which
led to a bunch of iterations of the
design side which led to a configuration
still the prototype you side we had
started to a series of UX goals start to
emerge and have a couple of examples of
like you know where we're in the in the
workflow these these goals kind of
manifest so the first one was all around
being able to sort of ground the users
mental model and well that's what that
sort of means is that we we end up kind
of taking the sort of traditional ml
workflow which yes is this a semi linear
process but has this tendency to sort of
circle back in on itself where like once
you get to a certain point like after
say evaluate your model you may circle
back and label some more images and then
kind of go back through this process
again but eventually the goal is to sort
of you know end up at the very last step
over here and start to like see what are
the different sort of subtasks or like
sort of user user user stories that sort
of aligned with these different sort of
themes that are that are part of each of
these steps so it might be like
something that's fairly straightforward
like you know well as a user I want to
name the data set so that I can recall
later or as a user I want to specify
whether this is single label
classification or multi-label
classification on the import side - you
know on the other side like as a user I
want to be able to access some code
samples so that I can you know be able
to implement my implement my model or
and deploy it and when those starts to
kind of we started to consult see some
sort of consolidation was seeing if we
can sort of map these different steps of
the workflow to specific States within
the application itself and so that where
that starts to kind of
come to play is unfortunately a little
washed out but the idea that there's a
there's a create form over here at the
left which sort of leads to this tab set
over here that encompasses these four
steps and you can sort of toggle between
images train evaluate and test and use
or predict and sort of be able to
because our tabs you can sort of like
navigate backwards and forwards so like
here's sort of like a maybe a little bit
easier to see or there's the crate form
and then over here you see the images on
the top left train evaluate and predict
the sort of representing those four
stages of the of the ML sort of flow
that you can serve go back in any
particular order and serve jump forward
in any particular order there's no sort
of like requirement to you to do all the
steps but there's still sort like this
forward momentum that sort of that sort
of propels you towards this this last
step over here another piece that kind
of came to the forefront was being able
to educate users on new concepts and by
new I sort of mean new to users that
have little ml expertise and so this
would be something that's it might be
around like progressive disclosure so
like the tooltip that I showed earlier
where it's like the leverage precision
is kind of this weird foggy concept to
people that might not have ml expertise
and then precision and recall they sound
intuitive but maybe we need to like
provide some additional text to help
sort of you know bring bring more
clarity to this particular term and so
this is something that you know we've
been doing a couple of subsequent
iterations on to see if we can you know
make this this language increasingly
clear to people that might have that
might struggle with with understanding
these these sort of broad concepts and
so it's something that we're you know
it's still kind of a work in progress
additionally things like you know
distinguishing between between a false
negative and a false positive would be
areas that we would sort of investigate
more fully in the in the in the detail
of you where we showed like the list of
predictions so here we we have a list of
labels and the scores they received
but then we also serve indicate which
one was the ground truth about this
little start over here and sort of
indicate like well this label because
it's because it was above 0.5 which was
the score threshold that yet set and it
was not the ground truth we're sort of
deeming that as a false positive and
then meanwhile this one that's below 0.5
that start is a false negative so try to
like kind of reintroduce these concepts
over and over and again through the
through the product itself is another
thing that we're trying to do to kind of
produce like a more a more you know
infused more user education directly
into the UI so that's sort of like kind
of Auto ml vision more or less in a
nutshell and we have two other products
as mentioned earlier that launched yet
next as well so we have Auto ml natural
language which is essentially kind of
like the same principle as autumn
elevation but it's dealing with
basically with with freeform
unstructured text sort of like documents
so yeah like and the sort of use cases
around that are yeah there's there's a
variety of them they're associated with
that and then down below we have Auto
translation which is more about being
able to take the existing translation
API and being able to sort of augment it
with your specific use cases so like if
there are you know certain needs that
were like certain words or idioms pieces
of vernacular that that that the current
translation API is struggling with if
you had like a whole series of samples
since since pairs you can pass sighted
to auto mode translation and build a
custom model for that so you can find
out more about autumn oh by going to
this link which is actually repeated
over here and this is sort of an also an
opportunity to promote our office hours
so if you have a lot of like questions
around the underlying technology for our
Domo or like want to find out more about
like how a lot of notes are works under
the hood it's possible that we go
through office hours we can pair you up
with somebody that might have more more
of that knowledge base on there all
right well thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you